dla mnie chwila
wejścia polski do unii europejskiej była wzruszająca
Jak dla wszystkich
ale również chcę podkreślić
że w tym momencie
pełniłem zaszczytną funkcję wiceministra
integracji europejskiej
i
tego nikt mi nigdy nie odbierze i nie odbierze lewicy
bo to my wprowadziliśmy polskę do unii europejskiej
tego samego Roku urodził się mój syn
więc mój syn jest moim euro dzidziusiem
wiem że NAS teraz ogląda i wszystkich pozdrawiam
którzy w
Roku wejścia polski do unii europejskiej się urodzili
jesteście
naszym klubom i jesteście również naszą szansą
bo to wejście
ta decyzja służy przede wszystkim przyszłym pokoleniom
wam i długo nad tym pracowaliśmy jako lewica
jako środowisko polityczne i jako polskie
gdzieś stoimy przed wieloma wyzwaniami
1 z najważniejszych to jest bezpieczeństwo
to jest bezpieczeństwo energetyczne
bezpieczeństwo zbrojne
i Unia Europejska dzisiaj powinna być solidarna
silna i w tej unii europejskich polska
powinna dać silny głos
tak Jak się dzisiaj to dzieje
w ramach trójkąta wajmarskiego
w ramach parlamentu europejskiego i instytucji
europejskiej polska powinna mieć twarz
lewicy i proeuropejskich ruchów
aniemorawieckiego
który jedzie do budapestu
żeby się ściskać
ze zwolennikiem putina panem premierem orbanem
tak nie może być
polska powinna być tym krajem
który nadaje tempo zmian w unii europejskiej
również traktatowych